bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver à
la une de ça vous regarde ce soir là dit
denis à paris cédric villani devrait
être exclu ce soir de la république en
mars benjamin griveaux dégringole le
clivage gauche droite revient en force
et l'écologie s'impose alors pourquoi
rien ne se passe comme prévu dans la
capitale l'élection du maire de paris
n'a jamais été aussi ouverte on en parle
ce soir avec plusieurs candidats sur ce
plateau dans notre grand débat dans un
instant quel rôle quel rôle doit jouer
le médecin dans la lutte contre les
violences conjugales
la majorité veut autoriser la levée du
secret médical à certaines conditions le
sujet est sensible
il touche au lien de confiance entre les
médecins et leurs patients et cette
mesure et discuter ce soir dans
l'hémicycle on en parlera enfin notre
grand témoin ce soir est un homme
d'image passionné par la politique il en
a filmé tous les aspects les plus
historiques comme les plus tragiques et
aujourd'hui il revient avec un livre une
lettre à sa petite fille anita serge
moati est avec nous ce soir voilà vous
savez tout c'est parti hashtag sévère
n'oubliez pas on y va
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
nos invités en plateau ce soir serge
moati bonsoir bonsoir merci infiniment
d'avoir accepté notre invitation vous
êtes notre grand témoin on a une heure à
passer ensemble les français vous
connaissent bien vous êtes un homme de
télévision producteur réalisateur vous
avez une pâte
une manière à vous de filmer la
politique on en parlera au plus près de
l'humain et vous publié aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui même ça sort aujourd'hui
cette lettre à votre petite fille d'être
amanita c'est chez fayard souvenir de
l'ardoisé magique ou voulu raconter
votre vie ce monde ancien dont vous
dites qu'il disparaît petit à petit on
en parlera tout à l'heure mais d'abord
paris vous connaissez bien paris en ce
moment la prise de l'hôtel de ville vous
l'avez même filmé en 2001
rien ne se passe comme prévu à nouveau
villani exclu en passe de l'être ce soir
griveaux à la peine dati tout sourire et
hidalgo en mer tranquille on en parle
avec vous il apporta bonsoir bonsoir
transfuge bois transfuge tout de suite
transfuge de l'équipe de gaspard gants
d'hiver dans l'équipe de cédric villani
que vous avez décidé de soutenir et donc
de rejoindre il ya quelques jours vous
serez sans doute candidate dans le 14e
arrondissement vous êtes journaliste et
spécialiste de l'écologie bonsoir ian
brossât
vous êtes adjoint au maire adjoint à la
maire de paris adjoint communiste
candidat dans le dix huitième sur la
liste d'anne hidalgo paris en commun
enfin j'accueille rudolf granier bonsoir
soit vous êtes tête de liste les
républicains dans le 18e
il s'agit cette fois-ci de la liste de
rachida dati dati pour paris je précise
tout de même que nous aurions aimé avoir
la présence d'un candidat ou d'un
soutien de benjamin griveaux mais coquin
n'a pu n'a souhaité venir participer à
ce débat je vous donne la parole dans un
instant celui qui nous plante le décor
de ce grand bazar de l'hôtel de ville
c'est stéphane stéphane blakowski si
j'ai bien compris
[Musique]
bonsoir mesdames
bonsoir messieurs bonsoir stéphane si
j'ai bien compris ce soir bah si j'ai
bien compris d'abord faut que m bennett
sinon je pourrai jamais vous dire ce que
j'ai compris c'est marqué la regarder et
incompris anne hidalgo c'est quand même
bon ben là favorite aujourd'hui des
municipales à paris en moi je m'y
attendais pas du tout bah je m'étais mis
en tête que hidalgo depuis son élection
était devenu la bête noire des
automobilistes dans un pays où 86 % des
gens sont propriétaires d'une voiture
dans un pays où les gens quand on
augmente le dz mettre le feu casse tout
bon ça me paraissait quand même assez
mal placé pour avoir une base de
popularité pour être la mère de la
capitale que détesté à ce point là les
voitures sauf qu'à paris la majorité des
habitants ban voiture la majorité n'a
pas exactement il ya un tiers seulement
des habitants
selon les dernières statistiques ons de
voiture à paris donc c'est vraiment une
34% aujourd'hui au tiers quoi sert cette
fait partie des nombreuses différences
qui existent entre paris reste de la fin
donc en fait quand inégal goody on se
débarrasse des voitures c'est sans doute
avant tout les banlieusards qui vont
être pénalisés mais les banlieusards et
votre pub minicipal à paris donc
pourquoi ce qu on leur ait à
s'embarrasser de leurs problèmes de
voiture évidemment non au contraire anne
hidalgo ce qu'elle veut faire c'est plus
de place au vélo un vélo où tous les
rues 100% des rustres et cyclable si
elle même s'il a été élu le premier ca
pour 2011 de plus en vélo qui était
d'ailleurs présenté aujourd'hui donc
c'est un programme écolo qu'elle propose
bah question quasiment d'ailleurs tout
le monde croit à remarquer la la la
couleur de ses affiches de campagne bon
serge klein ancien le code couleur du
parti socialiste rappelez moi c'est
comme sert aux juges et la regarder les
affiches et ben non elle a tout repeint
en vert fonds vert pour les têtes de
ligne calme et vous même salaire qu'un
petit cadeau
mais le ver est très très tendance en
politique vous l'avez santé agréable
mon sort pas un petit peu en verve bon
ben hilal go il a fait ça comme tout le
monde on simplement leur froideur on
vous êtes fous qui m'a dit ça qu'on
diffusait un reportage sur les lettres
la concurrence marois là c'est tout à
fait pas qu'y alors elle son principal
adversaire dans cette campagne
enfin pour l'instant là encore c'est une
surprise pour moi parce que moi je
pensais que tu es benjamin griveaux le
grand favori et je me disais ce comme
occasion de gagner d'avancé quoi au
second tour macron fait 90 % des voix
donc la grille vont ils se présentent il
est l'élu donc cessé après c'est évident
c'était sans compter la dissidence
vilaine et ben voilà ben macro nous
avait promis un nouveau monde
et puis finalement il ressemble pas mal
à l'ancien encore une fois je me tourne
vers serge votre s'agit si oui ça sera
toujours le même manière en fin d'année
car partie est convaincu de gagner une
élection qu'est ce qui se passe ça crée
des ambitions qui dit ambition dit
rivalité qui dit rivalité 10n
détestation interne division et ben
voilà on en est là ils sont divisés à la
nuit quand me voilà humain trop humain
ça ça n'a pas changé et donc finalement
villani refuse de tendre la main à
grimaud on les écoute mekhissi entre
l'appartenance est un appareil politique
et la fidélité
l'engagement pour la ville qui m'a fait
je choisi de rester fidèle aux
parisiennes et aux parisiens en
maintenant ma candidature librement à
l'envoyer la barbe demeure philippe
blanchi là je pense que macron s'arrache
les cheveux parce que quand on
additionne les scores de griveaux est de
l'île a ni on arrive à 26% donc il a
peut-être quoi créer un vrai socle le
fort pour une majorité est là finalement
avec ses divisions 10 d'un côté cesse de
l'autre c'est rachida dati mon païs en
deuxième position voilà pour les
municipales actuellement dans les
sondages quoi sauf que pour villani
reste une option c'est peut-être de
s'allier avec le candidat écolo d'élite
belliard le dirach isabelle tailleur
mais déjà servi de ma petite va faire
milani petit pourquoi ils pourraient
s'allier blanc avec il ya cette idée de
coalition pour le climat qu'à lens
non c'est les verts donc c'est david
d'elia mélanie a dit qu'ils étaient
intéressés donc ils pourraient
s'entendre il ya juste un truc qui comme
moi me fait tiquer c'est qu'au mois de
septembre et scali d'aline bélières à
propos de belhani donc regardant le
parisien est délimité review et qu'est
ce qui dit bon sinon je vous le dis je
suis lentilles vilaine je suis l'entv
dany comment peut-on être l'entv dany au
mois de septembre et puis finalement pas
bon c'est de la politique ch on en a vu
d'autres mais avouez quand même que
alors on arrive au paradoxe suivant vous
finalement alizés legault il y avait un
sondage en novembre aux docks ça fait
par griveaux d'ailleurs demandé plus tôt
par gréau dix 60% des parisiens ne
veulent pas khalid al go reste à la
mairie et pourtant aujourd'hui c'est la
grande fabrique nombreux ça ça se passe
un peu différemment voir que prévu tout
de même ça vous surprend vous ce
paradoxe là évidemment des péripéties
politiques macro marché grévaux non
parce que la réalité c'est que vous
l'avez dit anne hidalgo a été beaucoup
critiqué mais en réalité beaucoup des
réalisations qu'elle a mise en oeuvre
qui à l'époque ont été contestés sont
aujourd'hui plébiscités par les
parisiens prenaient la piétonisation des
voies sur berges on nous a dit pendant
des mois c'est terrible il ya même des
maires d'arrondissement qui maintenant
soutiennent monsieur griveaux qui avait
fait des recours en justice contre la
piétonisation des voies sur berge
aujourd'hui tout le monde dit que c'est
très bien et qu'on a eu raison de le
faire et on voit pas tout le monde
dany passage il défendra sa position
sauf que cette politique de réduction la
place de la voiture elle a permis depuis
maintenant cinq ans de réduire la
pollution de 15% elle a permis de
réduire le trafic automobile de 17% en a
par ailleurs laissé de la place au vélo
je pense que c'est une bonne politique
et donc des parisiens se disent surpris
donc c'est le bilan 1 qui commencerait à
infuser on va quand même revenir à
l'actualité et sectes à l'actualité et
vous concerne zabel saporta c'est
l'exclusion l'exclusion de cédric vs qui
vous arrangent pas un petit peu cette
exclusion parce qu'on a l'impression que
vous personnellement les marcheurs
s'étaient pas trop votre tasse de thé
non enfin moi je vois pas ça comme ça en
fait je moi je suis assez fier moi même
sommes très fiers de cédric villani
parce qu'au fond il a dit une chose il a
dit voilà moi je veux travailler pour la
coalition climat
c'est à dire je veux tendre la main aux
écologistes je veux que l'écologie soit
au coeur de notre projet je veux
travailler à un pacte de gouvernance
pour qu'enfin les choses aller beaucoup
plus vite parce que je vous entends tu
es ian brossât et c'est vrai qu'à ni
d'alcoa fait des choses mais là aussi
alain très joli programme n'a par
exemple le jet est là aussi un bilan qui
n'est pas très bon notamment vous savez
bien sûr le vélib qui est un fiasco sur
autolib qu'elle a arrêté et qui est un
autre fiasco
donc on a eu quand même quelques fiascos
et là moi je suis par exemple très
contente qu'elle soit très heureuse de
faire les cantines bio ce que je ne
comprends pas c'est comment se fait-il
qu'elle ne l'ait pas fait avant envoyée
donc moi je n'ai rien contre la personne
je vois juste qu'un outil bilan
peut-être un incident sur l'exclusion
sur l'exclusion mois ci voulait la
question c'est pas tellement ma relève
cédric villani d'aujourd'hui oui oui
bien ça va cédric vous savez c'est un
homme très fort c'est marrant d'ailleurs
parce qu'au fond je ne sais pas comment
ils ont pu penser que quelqu'un qui
était médaillé fields et qui s'étaient
battus 8 s'est battue qui est un grand
mathématicien pour être quelqu'un
finalement de faibles dans ses
convictions
donc voila moi ce que je comprends pas
c'est qu'effectivement là où vous avez
raison c'est que ben le nouveau monde
s'il ressemble à ce point là l'ancien
fer d exclusion était passé sur l'idée
d'alliances
alliance que propose la coalition pour
le climat que aux avis le bélial il les
temps ça m'a attendu jusqu'à la france
insoumise
c'est là que j'ai du mal à imaginer
villani et légendes la france est
soumise dans la même majorité là où vous
avez tort c'est que c'est pas comme ça
qu'il faut voir les choses regarder ce
qui se passe en allemagne
en allemagne on se pose pas la question
d'une qui est dedans on se pose la
question de ce qu'on va faire et moi
c'est ça qui me dérange en france
aujourd'hui c'est pour ça je me suis
lancé en politique c'est la question
c'est qu'est ce qu'on va faire ensemble
qu'est ce que ça raconte comment on va
faire de la transition énergétique
beaucoup plus rapidement que ce qui a
été fait jusqu'à maintenant comment on
va repenser des quartiers apaisé anne
hidalgo elle veut faire juste le centre
piétonniser moi je voudrais qu'ils aient
des quartiers apaiser un petit peu
partout et notamment dans les cas du 18
g sur l'écologie mais on va rester sur
la politique parce que ce soit rien
bureau exécutif et ce soir peut-être que
toute la liste 1 tous les policiers de
cette règle à nice seront exclus du
parti
quelles conséquences concrètes ça change
rien est-ce qu'il n'est pas plus libre
au fonds pourra faire des coalitions
est-ce qu'il n'ait pas pu libre
vis-à-vis de leader aurait dû l'oregon
il a plu deux ovaires grand les bras et
lui a pas dit il attendait que bill
annie parent pauvre on s'attendait à ce
qu'ils disent travailler en fait le vrai
président du travail ils avancent c'est
tout il travaille sans le sou on est
quand même
l'anssi monde est en train de revivre en
réalité on l'a pas on l'a pas perdu tout
ça respire la combine la déclaration de
six mois qui sont lentilles lentilles
villani par belliard on a accès voilà on
a du mal à comprendre mais du coup là
quelque chose
demos s'arrête un instant sur la
dissidence parce que des dissidents et
vous si je préfère même ne serait-ce ou
sur l'image d'une famille une famille
politique qui excluent ne s'est pas un
bon signe de santé en général
voilà nous l'exclusion c'est pas quelque
chose qu'on a pratiqué vous avez
pratiqué
en attendant bon prendre parti et la
courtage pour une fois qu'on a une
famille politique unie qui se respecte
ne pas maintenir chine a déjà fait des
parisiens qui nous regardent mais il n'y
a peut-être pas que des parisiens sur
explique ont quand même parce que des
dissidences vous en avez et rainbow à
nous à paris dans le xvème illégaux
chuter pareil dans la commission
nationale d'investiture des républicains
a parlé elle a investi 17 candidats dont
rachida dati les plus d'un an
et si on se souvient un petit peu
d'histoire il ya plus d'un an une
fallait investir personnes il fallait
même pas présenter un candidat des
républicains
aujourd'hui quand on va sur le terrain
quand on parle avec les parisiens
on se rend compte que l'offre politique
unie c'est le cas et des personnes
qu'ils soutiendront rachida dati fait le
retour des collages autre droite gauche
alors gauche droite c'est maintenant de
l'inspecteur et la droite et le centre
ne sont pas morts à paris première
nouvelle je suis quelque chose dans
notre façon de faire dans notre façon de
dire on est rester nous mêmes
cette sincérité cette authenticité ça
parle en politique aujourd'hui on voit
très bien kelly mandat du président de
république emmanuel macron les français
ne sont pas du tout dupe
faut arrêter de les prendre pour des
visites pour des imbéciles moi je me
fâche c'est à dire que je pense que dans
une campagne on a besoin de clarté
on a besoin de dire les choses or on
peut dire ce qu'on veut sur ce qu'a fait
anne hidalgo sur ce qu'elle a envie de
faire quelque chose et on a le droit
d'être contre
absolument mais au moins le cap il
éclaire sur toute une série de questions
nous nous répondons clairement est-ce
qu'il faut continuer à réduire la place
de la voiture oui est-ce qu'il faut
continuer à faire des pistes cyclables
oui est ce que le fait qu'ils n'ont eu
cesse qu'il faut continuer à encadrer
les loyers oui est ce qu'il faut faire
du logement social notamment dans les
arrondissements qui en comptent trop peu
oui et c est peu dire
et bien sûr mais surtout si vous
permettez mais si vous le permettez je
me permets déterminé être élu c'est tout
le temps répondre à des questions
simples que nous posent les électeurs et
le dire de manière extrêmement claire or
on peut dire ce qu'on veut
anne hidalgo et rachida dati elles
répondent totalement inverse sur ces
questions là mais au moins c'est clair
et puis à côté de ça je vous le dis
isabelle saporta j'écoute ce que dit
cédric villani
je suis incapable de dire aujourd'hui
les parisiens sont incapables de dire
aujourd'hui ce qu'il répond à ces
questions est ce qu'il est pour ou
contre l'encadrement des loyers je ne
sais pas est ce qu'il est pour ou contre
par exemple la réduction de la place de
la voiture je ne sais pas en
l'occurrence vous avez dit que nous
avons un bilan lui aussi à l'assemblée
nationale il n'a il ne s'est pas opposé
mais quand on perd du temps qu'ils
passent du temps à faire des combines
politiques qui a regardé qui doit être
numéro 2 et numéro 3 quand personne ne
sait où on va effectivement perdu tant
par les votes non non mais c'est très
envie d'agir revient le glyphosate
français de s'être fait rire alors là là
d'ssus complètement tranquille puisque
moi-même je les ai dénoncé c'est ce que
je trouvais j'avais dit que la platine
donc si voulez moi je sais des
discussions que j'ai eues avec lui entre
temps il a évolué entre temps il a
changé
il a fait beaucoup de choses avec eux
matthieu orphelin avec delphine batho
sur les questions environnementales
par ailleurs il s'est beaucoup imprégné
des questions de conditions animales
savez moi j'ai pas votre je vois bien
souligner un truc dans cette équipe
hidalgo vous êtes persuadé que vous avez
raison sur tout et que vous détenez la
vérité absolue et que tous les autres ne
sont pas avoir parce que j'ai bien mais
je me sens bien je vois bien de crise à
votre projet une espèce que c'est pas
c'est pas c'est pas en fait c'est pas
bien parce qu'en fait je trouve que
paris souffre de sa la plus pour moi le
plus grand capital de paris cesson
humain c'est de trouver une façon que
paris soit apaisée et de construire
ensemble
vous voulez me dire que effectivement
dans cette coalition climat y aura des
gens très différents
oui il y aura des gens très différents
je vous dis qu'il ya des gens qui disent
tout et leur contraire c'est un autre
problème
mais voyez vous c'est toujours les
petites phrases maintenant c'est la
vérité non c'était à laurent sa
cohérence quant aux électeurs en sont là
et juste avec l encadrement
contrairement sur quel projet un peu la
voir on est en train de travailler sur
un projet commun sur la loi sur
l'énergie
justement c'est quoi la clarté
aujourd'hui jusqu'à présent qu'est ce
qui se passait entre le premier et le
second tour
on avait des gens jusqu'au premier tour
qui se taper dessus qui disait qui se
détestaient et entre le premier et le
second tour en trois jours alors il
devenait tous amoureux ils étaient tous
d'accord il fallut et ils s'allier et il
se balade entre allianz qui voulait la
faire en jouant toute transparence on
dit voilà on avait des accords on va y
travailler
on a des accords on va faire un pacte de
gouvernance moi je suis désolé je suis
très fier de ça c'est pour ça que je me
suis engagé en politique
pressé de faire le trait d'union entre
des gens très différents ce que vous
nous des titres vous avez tout faire
pour faire une alliance avec les
écologistes avant le premier tour et
vous la ferez entre les deux tours si
vous ne parvenez pas avec celui qui sera
le mieux placé et vincent vous le
reconnaissez vous savez david belliard
séduite et bien religion et david des
dégâts qu'ils ont cassé des règles et
camille abily bien sûr et david est
quelqu'un d'extraordinaire enfin c'est
un jeune homme très courageux qui se bat
et qui dit aujourd'hui l'écologie doit
être au coeur et qui prend le risque au
fond de dire ouvrons-nous moi je trouve
des longues virées année pourrait se
désister en faveur de david bénard se
retirer est là où il ne s'est pas
retirée alors avec griveaux c'est ça et
bien un pacte de gouvernement je crois
que c'est ça oui faudrait votre
gouvernance on va arriver sur les sujets
de fond vallée sur l'écologie mais je
voudrais votre regard est ce que ça
change la politique quand vous entendez
ça vous aviez film et 2001 il y avait
déjà des dissidents on se souvient
évidemment seguin tiberi mais est-ce que
c'est nouveau
vraiment non s'il ya de ce qui me frappe
là un peu c'est que je n'entends pas par
lui un peu mais lui les corps mon
camarade de gauche monsieur bros a géré
ça que j'aime beaucoup des uns et
je crois qu'au ministère oui j'étais
très programme commun et mais je suis
d'une génération qui parlait beaucoup
d'idéologie 20,2 de gauche droite
élevé dans cette culture là et ça a été
pour moi très important dans ma vie très
et je renie pas ça du tout une seconde
même si je vis autrement même si je
n'obtiens porte mais parfois ont voté
vers bon mais non mais le vert mais
c'est un premier pas est bon mais est en
tout cas je suis attaché à ça et là je
n'entends pas cette culture là qui est
la mienne à gauche qu'à droite son
plateau avec le débat est davantage sur
le fond d'exiger les propositions est ce
que le débat avance davantage sur le
fond ou pas on allait changer le nom pas
souper un peu de ça aussi serge moati
c'est pas moi moi moi pas vous mais je
n'ai pas moi enfin pas moi oui vous êtes
aussi agrégé conversation et moi mais je
vous demande de de colonne vertébrale
oui par exemple ce monsieur que je
trouve très sympathique jeu grenier jeu
pour sauver la chance parce que moi ils
arrêtent pas non mais bien sûr non mais
c'est filmé des gens de toutes sortes
c'est pas la question mais je sentais le
à droite je comprenais soit vrai tu vois
je vois maintenant on met et et là je
comprends plus à part lui genre parce
que je les ai donc je sais mais sinon je
ne comprends pas par un blues est une
énigme pour moi alors je pense que si
vous voulez l'idée aujourd'hui
finalement c'est que collectivement en
avance de façon pragmatique sur le fond
parce que oui maison d'un souper des
postures navy changement a dit oui mais
je suis désolé on en a on en a soupé des
gens qui se disaient confirmant de
gauche et qui après voté la déchéance de
nationalité voyez il ya un moment il ya
les paie
coupé du monde il ya comment on est
quand même d'aller mois de ça la vraie
chose est de regarder l'écologie dans
cette campagne parce que ce qui peut
vendre ap c'est qu'on est quand même
dans une forme de concours lépine avec
des des projets parfois farfelus ou des
propositions choc c'est selon vous a
préparé un petit podium
il est signé ma été vraiment quand on
regarde les programmes écolo des
candidats à paris on se demande jusqu'où
ira la surenchère dans le top-5 d'abord
il y à la promesse de cédric villani son
idée à lui c'est de désengorger paris en
enlevant les thalys de la gare du nord
pour les transférer dans une nouvelle
gare à saint denis
il y a aussi l'idée d' anne hidalgo qui
veut remplacer 60000 places de
stationnement tout simplement par des
pistes cyclables trop souvent à paris en
matière de sécurité routière c'est la
loi de la jungle et c'est pas possible
mais il y avait mieux voici notre podium
en troisième place le candidat écolo
david belliard et sa promesse de
déterrer la bièvre une rivière enfouis
depuis plus de 100 ans
belle trouvaille également du côté de
benjamin griveaux qui propose la
suppression de la gare de l'est pour
créer un central park à la française
déplacé une gare et construire un parc
voilà qui a déjà suscité en 24 heures à
peine
des moqueries et beaucoup de sarcasme
n'ayez vraiment aucune inquiétude
ce sont les mêmes qui appelle sans cesse
à faire davantage pour l'écologie et qui
disent qu'il est impossible de
reconquérir 30 hectares d'espacés verts
dans paris mais personne n'arrive à la
cheville de celui qui a lancé les
hostilités
gaspard ganzer il proposait bien tout
simplement la suppression du
périphérique pour en faire un parc
circulaire de 140 hectares
autant dire que s'il était le maire il
ne se fera pas que des copains
isabelle saporta on n'est pas dans une
surenchère qui n'est pas forcément très
très sérieuse là dans cette campagne
c'est le concours lépine franchement
déterrer la bièvre supprimer les
périphéries c'est joli déterrer la
bièvre et si vous voulez en vrai je
pense que paris se tournerait un tout
petit peu plus justement verts attendent
les parisiens vraiment vous croyez moi
ce que je pense nous pensons que
effectivement ils attendent en tout cas
une chose moi que pour laquelle je
bataille corps et âme c'est qu'on se
retourne enfin vers la scène et qu'on
fasse du fret fluvial sur la seine
plutôt que d'avoir des livraisons en
camion en permanence la scène et est
sous investis à paris c'est bien et
c'est pas la priorité
bah moi je pense que c'est une des
priorités alors vraiment pour pour nous
dans la future mandature c'est une des
priorités parce que un tiers à peu près
de la pollution des embouteillages à
paris ce sont les livraisons donc si on
ne réfléchit pas très noir le via bien
sûr au transport fluvial
on ne pense pas à paris de demain en
fait vous pourriez aller dans ce sens
ian brossât
c'est pas une mauvaise idée pour le coup
on peut pas mettre toutes ces idées que
c'est une idée qui n'est pas défendu par
votre candidat mais par david belyi a
nommé pour le couple on sait qu'il faut
pour le coup ne sont pas à mettre sur le
même plan il ya des idées qui sont
sérieuses et puis il ya les vôtres 2000
places de jeux actuellement supprimer
les six de nos gars
donc c'est le zéro voiture comme énoncé
pas le zéro voiture mais c'est réduire
la place de la voiture parce qu'il ya
quand même une situation assez aberrante
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a que 10
% des trajets à paris qui se font en
voiture et la voiture c'est 50% de
l'espace public donc vous avez un
décalage qui n'est pas normal qu'il
n'est pas acceptable et donc à un moment
donné il faut rééquilibrer tout ça donc
oui mais là tout le monde ne peut pas et
nous disons donc qu'il faut réduire la
place de la voix suave en a commenté
augmenter la place dédiée aux vélos et
aux piétons parce que les piétons c'est
quand même le premier mode de
circulation dans la capitale mais
j'insiste sur un point
l'écologie c'est le socle du du
programme défendu par anne hidalgo c'est
une écologie sociale et c'est une
écologie qui n'est pas exclu en ce n'est
pas une écologie qui vise simplement à
organiser le bien-être des gens qui vont
déjà bien par exemple lorsque nous
disons
il faut avancer vers la gratuité des
transports en commun la gratuité des
transports en commun nous avons fait la
gratuité des transports pour les
personnes âgées
nous avons fait la gratuité des
transports pour les enfants de 4 à 11
ans et nous voulons aller vers la
gratuité de tous les moins de 18 ans
pour qu'ils puissent de cette manière là
circuler sans payer dans les transports
en commun ça pour le coup je pense que
ça illustre bien la bouche de micron pas
parce que secondes et s'est par ailleurs
ils sont étendues à la région mais alors
qu à saissac sujet la parole redonne
cramé sont des républicains nous
répondons à utiliser quelque chose que
je trouve est hyper important tout à
l'heure il faisait en fait ça manque
d'idéologie mais moralité n'ont cédé au
logis qui firent au dogmatisme et quand
on traite de l'écologie par dogmatisme
on arrive à faire quand même des grandes
erreurs qui notamment la première c'est
de ne pas répondre aux préoccupations
des parisiens donc il ya des idées qui
peuvent être très simple c'est de
l'écologie du quotidien de l'écologie
positive qu'il faut proposer
il faut arrêter de sanctionner quand on
propose de supprimer 60 mille voitures
soit son espace de parking pardon c'est
pas que les personnes du grand paris que
je préférais banlieusards qui sont
sanctionnés sont aussi des familles
soient aussi des personnes à mobilité
réduite sont des entrepreneurs
commerçants on entend bien aller on a
été critiqués anne hidalgo oui mais en
dix ans mais c'est une folie
il ya des personnes et vous proposez
quoi mais simplement de regarder
l'exemple de strasbourg on a quand même
une cohabitation aujourd'hui on est dans
une arène une anarchie totale ya des
gens qui ont peur de marcher sur des
trottoirs aujourd'hui parce qu'ils vont
se faire taper par une trottinette par
un vélo par qui encore donc simplement
sa médiation
on peut très bien vivre d'une façon
beaucoup plus apaisé sur les
déplacements mais sans forcément
chercher à stigmatiser d'une part il
m'avoue donné comme priorité tout le
monde peut très bien vivre ensemble ça
suffit on veut donner la priorité aux
entreprises comme ça on peut pas diriger
les uns contre les autres de façon floue
profession pour le climat par simplement
dit il faut garder allez tout le monde
ensemble
les vélos et les voitures y aurait t on
sur la rénovation des vassues urbaine
aujourd'hui dans le 18ème arrondissement
on a 27 % des logements qui ne répondent
pas à des critères correcte cela c'est
la rénovation terre c'est la révolution
sa maison plus tôt les plus importants
plutôt qu'au niveau inférieur comme
combat mais message non la note à la fin
du mois c'est pour chacun des
parisiennes et des paraissait pour
sabine des parisiennes et des parisiens
pas bon ensuite c'est quand même assez
aberrant que des factures de chauffage
explose et le 18e est concerné on a 70 %
des logements qui sont dans ce cas là
qui sont 17e 18e 19e 20e
là où la circulation parce qu'il a été
décidé de manière dogmatique de
l'interdire dans le centre-ville a été
reporté c'est pour faire un bilan
énergétique également des écoles
aujourd'hui sur la mandature aînés moins
300 de fait soit moins de la moitié à
l'heure des logements plus propre qu'on
entend 7,7 priori faire et ne pas faire
la guerre à la voiture préfère chez nous
le qualitatif au quantitatif wilhelm par
rober tony's et paris encore une fresque
on propose pour pour le climat moi je
vais pas taper sur la proposition d'anne
hidalgo sur le vélo quand je trouve
qu'elle est bonne - la question n'est
pas de taper dessus et la question c'est
pourquoi ne l'at elle pas fait avant moi
la question c'est toujours le bilan le
programme que vous présentez là il me
paraît très intéressant par contre je
comprend pas non plus quand vous dites
nous on fait donc et de bilan mais
pendant cette année d'algues aux piétons
changeait pas encore rachida dati donc
va la crise imola c'est sur une roche et
donc donc tout ça pour vous dire tout à
l'heure j'étais un petit peu choqué
quand vous avez dit nous on travaille
pour une écologie de la solidarité est
pas une une écologie des gens qui vont
bien mais quand par exemple vous
proposer la piétonisation du centre
en quoi vous travaillez pour le 18e pour
le 19e pour le 20e pour ces quartiers
qui sont le long du périphérique
moi j'ai un souci avec ça nous avons un
souci avec ça quand on voit aujourd'hui
que on a un métro alors je sais que ce
n'est pas directement paris c'est aussi
la question
les métros et de l'ile-de-france qui est
truffé de particules fines
qu'est ce qu'on fait quand ans qu'on met
enfin le turbo donc si vous voulez ya un
moment c'est facile de
2 comment dire d'être toujours dans
quelque chose de très clivant mais moi
la question n'est pas au fond de savoir
pourquoi commencer quand enfin on fait
ensemble dans chaque quartier des
quartiers apaisé pas la petite balle
sans vous parler d'un projet écologique
social ça c'est politique c'est juste
payer vous piétonniser le centre là où
évidemment c'est mieux que ce
périphérique pour répondre à isabelle
saporta qui dit des choses avec
lesquelles je suis par ailleurs assez
assez d'accord on peut dire que hidalgo
n'a pas assez fait en matière de lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique
on ne peut pas dire qu'elle n'a rien
fait d'ailleurs on nous a beaucoup
critiqué
on nous a beaucoup dit au cours de la
dernière mandature qu'on a trop fait et
maintenant on nous dit vous n'avez pas
assez fait je crois que d'ailleurs que
je préfère être dans la situation
actuelle que dans la situation dans
laquelle nous étions il ya quelques mois
et nous sommes très fiers d'avoir fait
ce que nous avons fait notamment le
développement des pistes cyclables ce
qui fait qu'à paris on a déjà 1000 km de
pistes cyclables et oui il faut aller
plus loin c'est grillé en attente de
service bien pratique il se trouve que
ça tombait pas si mal et pour ce qui
concerne la piétonnisation bien
évidemment qu'il faut pas se limiter au
centre de paris
bernard et il faut le faire aussi le
prochain maire de paris ce sera le plus
écologiquement par partage est là qu est
ce qu est ce que vous voyez monter ce
sujet ça fera la différence à votre avis
oui mais tout le monde est écolo donc
c'est ça ou je comprends plus rien tout
le monde est écolo d'accord donc alors
la trace d'un rachida dati l'écologie
vous l'avez vu comment c'est plus écolo
que moi tu meurs
comment vous la voyez place des
batteuses la de bonus de débat là parce
que moi je serais moi je suis d'accord
avec tout le monde fait comme ça oui
bien sûr est normal lors du débat tarit
pas prendre partie non mais c'est pas ça
mais il n'y a rien de cleaver entre vous
et moi mais c'est pas moi qui vais
apprendre ça ian brossât tiède en béton
forme interpellé ça oui non mais je
conseil de paris 1 7% said au conseil de
paris a plu vous travaillez ensemble
vous faites des coalitions sur chaque
projet donc cette idée est de faire
semblant de se taper dessus toute la
journée
alors qu'à la fin on travaille ensemble
sur des projets communs moi je trouve
que ça pour le coup c'est très ancien
monde pardonnez moi quoi largement est
c'est lourdingue le truc entre anciens
m'ont du nouveau monde c'est vraiment
dingue on ne le prenez pas pour vous
sert jalouse à la présente vous écoutez
moi je suis fille bon mais non mais
c'est pas ça mais je ne comprends pas
qu'ils rien de aller j'ai envie de vous
voir vous et riz que les français soient
là c'est de la merde oui mais qu'est ce
qu'on va dire ah non moi je veux pas que
des parisiens vivre avec ce côté
angélique que madame sur le côté moi je
veux que les parisiens vivent mieux
alors le mec
couach aigles étaient ses véhicules
n'est qu'on s'étripe les se trouve qu'il
ya des choses qu'on peut partager avec
ian brossât je suis regardé chose qu'on
peut mentionner avec rachida l'étude
entre le corps et d'albert et le nom des
artistes d'ailleurs qu'est-ce que vous
répondez là c'est peut-être qu aurait pu
vous dire à représentants de la lys
griveaux à ceux qui pensent qu au fond
vous êtes un peu le tremplin l'une de
l'autre
enfin je veux dire annie des réseaux et
si la date si c'est ce que vous êtes mal
à s'assumer d'entraîner dans la campagne
du facile à penser bon je trouve ça un
peu regrettable
rachida dati dit qu'elle avait du
respect pour anne hidalgo et fierté nous
n'en savons rien que dans la carte et
donc si nous nous sommes clairs et que
les parisiennes et les parisiens vote
pour notre projet
soyez assurés que nous mettrons en
oeuvre c'est quand même quelque chose
qui déjà au niveau politique assez
novateur pour terminer d'essayer de
comprendre quelque chose au rapport de
force je vois les lignes en présence
déjà on est allé demander à frédéric
dabi de l'ifop de nouveau durant petit
peu si on pouvait savoir qui allait
gagner
à moins de deux mois des exemples ici
pelle à paris la situation du rapport de
force électoral reste incertain même si
elle tend à voir les deux blocs de
gauche et de droite sont très
structurant à paris
revenir en force les enquêtes
d'intentions de vote à dernière menée
par l'ifop et fiducial pour le jdd radio
donne une avance pour anne hidalgo 25%
d'attention
qui devance rachida dati qui pour la
première fois arrive en deuxième
position la liste et l'air devant celle
de benjamin griveaux et celle de cédric
villani qui pâtissent de la fracturation
du bloc macro niel macron été la
première force à paris avec 35% à
l'élection présidentielle anne hidalgo
arrive en tête donc quasiment toutes les
catégories sauf les personnes âgées
elle surperforme dans les
arrondissements de gauche et parvient
pour le moment mais ce sera un signe
peut-être de danger pour elles à mettre
à distance a relégué europe écologie les
verts dans le sens de jeanne reçues sur
hummer forme dans les arrondissements
bien des gens gauche y est c'est pas mal
dans là où c'est plus compliqué pour
elle déjà elle arriva à gagner des
années sur ce sondage apparemment c'est
la lecture que pour en avoir une semaine
après sortie à notre sondage on voit qu
anne hidalgo régresse dans l'est dans
les importants vote et rachida dati
montrent donc bon le raisonnement mon
avis ne tient pas dans vos réserves de
voix les électeurs pourquoi voulez vous
qu'on cherche à avoir des alliés
détruire les électeurs bien sûr on fait
campagne le premier fait une campagne de
premier tour pour le moment vous allez
pas nous mettre faire un procès en
sincérité on voit que la yade et les
partages possible même si peut-être n'y
aura pas d'alliance à lui fort
je veux les manches pour venir pour le
voir mais ça nationale rage mais
pourriez vous alliez mais ce sont ceux
tentés d'avoir une majorité avec équipe
qui qui vote des élections ce sont des
appareils politiques ce sont des
structures non sont des électeurs sur
les parisiens
donc c'est à eux c'est eux qui font une
majorité personne d'autre c'est pas des
saints pas des appareils politiques qui
font ça la campagne est encore longue il
as deux mois et demi c'est ça cette
semaine tout le corps mais on ne lit pas
directement un maire joseph apprendre de
tentes où il va parler un peu de vous à
présent faire je mourrai ici on va
parler de votre livre bien sûr dans
lequel je le disais vous vous raconter
mais d'abord ahmed tazir s'est penché
sur votre cas et sur la relation vous
avez tissé avec vos objets les hommes et
les femmes politiques regardent
j'ai rendez vous et vous rendez vous et
vous festi'neuf boutin quand j'ai rendez
vous avec vous michel rocard sera dévoué
christiane taubira j'ai rendez vous et
que marine le pen aujourd'hui c'est nous
qui avons rendez vous avec vous serge
moati l'homme est avant tout une oreille
ils écoutent serge il écoute ça peut
servir quand on et documentariste comme
lui c'est que serge avec ce ton bien à
lui aime filmer les coulisses des
campagnes électorales c'est même le
spécialiste du genre tout commence dans
les années 70 celui qui lui a donné sa
chance c'est lui françois mitterrand
serge moati sera son conseiller pour
l'audiovisuel son réalisateur attitré
mais tuerie une aventure professionnelle
et humaine des buts car chez lui tout
s'entremêle le boulot et l'affectif
yoann gillet a travaillé côte à côte
avec serge moati durant huit années
françois mitterrand venait souvent dans
les conversations vous savez que serge
moati et orphelins et que les figures
comment dirais-je paternel maternelle
sont très importantes pour lui et quand
il me parlait de mitterrand à chaque
fois je voyais le petit enfant quelque
part moati qu'il n'était plus mais enfin
dans sa tête nous parler d'un grand
homme un grand personnage peut-être d'un
père caméra au poing
serge moati film un autre animal
politique
il le fait même chanter
un jour
jean-marie le pen et serge moati près de
30 ans de relations souvent amical qu'on
peut combattre quelqu'un pour ses idées
et le trouver sympathique par ailleurs
dans la vie avant de lui faire ses
adieux 25 ans retourne je le quittais
avec ses incantations ses visions ces
sombres prophéties et ses obsessions sur
un détail sous durafour crématoire
cette toute récente from et adieu à
celui qui avait perdu sa force et ses
ennemis la presse indigne à quoi joue
serge moati le débat est tout vert
serge moati rappelle souvent qu'il est
juif francs-maçons socialiste a priori
tout ce que déteste le front national et
hilali bas il faut aller voir son
contraire parce qu'on n'explique pas un
phénomène politique avec d analyse
froide distante lointaine c'est que
serge et empathique îles héron un
caméléon
il s'adapte à toutes les situations
disent ses proches quand vous filmez à
marseille avec serge moati la politique
en train de se faire vous marchez sur le
vieux port vous faites arrêter par la
droite
renaud muselier au serge et moi un goût
bien boire un coup et puis ensuite par
la gauche or serge bien et puis par tous
les partis alors vous refiler les verts
parce qu'il pouvait pas tout boire donc
en cachette je buvais les verts etc
parce qu'il fallait effectivement créé
cette empathie qui faisait qu'ensuite on
avait des accès que les autres n'avaient
pas voilà le secret être là où les
autres ne sont pas toujours au bon
endroit au bon moment
c'est peut-être pour cela me dit on que
vous avez été de plus en plus nombreux à
le suivre
vous êtes bien vous êtes vraiment bien
sur lcp de la chaîne qui dit on voit la
politique en grand et voilà j'ai saigné
ahmed tazir et un grand merci à y
résider pour les archers bravo ce qui
nous rappelle que vous avez travaillé
dans cette maison oui bien sûr des
années serge moitié l'affectif
l'empathie mais c'est votre marque de
fabrique
je sais pas si c'est sûrement pas une
fabrique en tout cas c'est
comme ça profondément enfin c'est pas
une marque de feu ben ne croyez pas que
c'est un truc mais des gens j'adore
filmer des gens j'ai été privé de photos
de mes parents parce qu'ils sont morts
quand j'étais jeune et j'ai découvert
qu'il y avait des images en mouvement
c'était le cinoche et j'ai adoré ça et
j'adore garder des traces des choses
parce que j'ai pas de trace m'a beaucoup
je n'en finis je salue l'arrivée
d'aurélien pradié députés les
républicains et de galles le break avec
qui on va parler dans la dernière partie
de cette émission d'un sujet grave
les violences conjugales je vais vous
pouvez intervenir dans cette interview
si vous le voulez est ce qu'ils vous ont
touché les critiques les critiques sur
jean marie le pen un nom ce qui m'a ce
qui m'a frappé au moins vous savez bon
juge d'une fils de déporté etc et genre
il fallait pas donc que je parle à le
pen c'est ridicule c'est ridicule c'est
pas comme ça qu'on avance et qu'on
l'entend j'ai fait des films sur la
haine antisémite jeu on en parle
beaucoup en france en ce moment j'ai
fait des films là dessus j'ai fait le
tour du monde des parti néo-nazi de par
le monde
il fallait qu'en france j'entende pas le
type qui disait le point de détail
enfin enfin et sanaa comme vous le dites
dans votre film où je sais pas si c'est
moi qui dis ou je sais pas quoi
je ne dis ma l'aï enfin veiller j'adore
film et je voulais comprendre ce que
disait le pen dernier c'est bernard
cazeneuve
oui d'ailleurs c'était pendant que
charlie hebdo l'hyper kashi avez vous
envie de filmer aujourd'hui mais qu'est
ce que porte sur les hommes politiques
du nouveau monde que vous n'aimez pas
seront de plus nouveau monde se présente
il ya peut-être un projet mais je vous
en parlerai quand ça sera montée
complète donc là il ya encore de l'envié
de filmer le personnel peut-il bien
aujourd'hui je suis tombé sur blessure
mais je veux comprendre je veux je veux
c'est mon métier que j'adore ça j'adore
ça le jeu je déteste le côté de se
détester fait je vois comment dire je
déteste ça et donc pour moi c'est
important d'avoir une caméra souple donc
il ya encore quelque chose affirmé
aujourd'hui parce qu'on
vous voyez avec michel rocard avec
françois mitterrand robert badinter
christiane taubira il y en a encore de
cette trempe-là de ce niveau là
aujourd'hui
oui bien sûr par exemple je pense que
macron est un personnage que oui qui est
passionnant qui vous intéressent
passionnant et donc vraiment pour moi
c'est capital enfin j'ai dit que non je
crois pas qu'ils font mieux avant après
c'est idiot et la politique à la
télévision
c'est à dire la l'impression que ça
n'intéresse plus personne vous croyez
que c'est partout la ligue 1 est ce
qu'on pense que si on en parle mal ou
c'est parce que là encore il ya plus
rien à montrer
je vous pose la question aux messieurs
où vous parlez des chaînes d'info
continue que ça qu'on parle d'eux à des
chaînes d'information continue je parle
des émissions politiques qui ont le
moins de 10 ans ce cadre oui d'accord je
sais mais parce que parce que ça arrête
pas quoi et puis moi y ait une troupe
qui me désole en ce moment c'est la
haine vraiment je pars dont je vous prie
de marché eh bien oui je me passais du
tout j'aime pas ça du tout enfin on y
dans une démocratie on peut s'affronter
on peut se discuter on peut mais pas
dans la débattre mais pas dans l'aisne
enfin j'ai vraiment ça me blesse
profondément à votre classe hier jean
françois kahn disait qu'on allait
peut-être dans le mur si on ne
réagissait pas il fallait regarder nos
erreurs en face messieurs sinon c'est
marine le pen qui oui c'est autre chose
à dire ça c'est autre chose et j'en
passe ont bien sûr bien sûr et donc il
faut
oui enfin bon bref moi y compris
souvenirs de l'ardoisé racontez nous
racontez nous d'abord cet objet qu'est
ce qu'il représente pour vous cette
ardoise magique
dans cette lettre anita votre petite
fille dès ma première petite fille de 2
ans et demi et non le le truc c'est que
au départ c'est l ardoise magique qui
était mon personnage presque centrale
ardoise magique
vous savez on a tous eu ça quand on
était gamins enfin en tout cas moi prof
ça s'efface il fait ce que j'ai je vous
hais ce geste ça s'efface bon et du
courrier aux éternels oui et je vous
disais j'ai 73 ans bon sens pour soi je
m'efface moi même ça s'efface pas je
m'efface et puis je lis freud d'un
copain un mot à ce canal joli joli
freud et freud dit mais non on ne
croyait pas que ça s'efface il reste des
traces si vous travaillez un peu le truc
et ça peut remonter
voilà ça m'a bouleversé c'est à vous de
faire 6 mois qui avait la première fois
j'avais écris moi j'avais écrit papa
m'aime pas il tombe là dessus angoisse
quelques 6 il a effacé il est dit papa
tu aimes pas ils t'adorent et j'étais
plus j'étais bouleversé ça ferait une
fois j'avais sarr je raconte ça ma
petite fille évidemment et ma petite
fille puisque j'y viens et a énormément
de tendresse il ya beaucoup de joie
familiale
bien sûr vous avez pour cette petite
fille il promet un stade j oui oui oui
parce que je surfe heulin il faut pas
oublier ça j'ai perdu mes deux parents
que j'avais 11 ans et ça vous marque
définitivement comme j'en dise on cesse
un jour d'être orphelin c'est en train
de venir grâce à la naissance de la
petite ce que je lui écris toi toi et je
lui donne une partie de l'héritage
amoureux le mien et je lui raconte des
histoires moi parce qu'on a peut
raconter des histoires en v quand mon
père déporté pendant qu'il parlait
jamais de la déportation
il me racontait il me chantait des
chansons de ce qu'ils chantaient dans
les trucs il me parle de sa loge
maçonnique qu'il avait créé
avec des voulu raconter tous disent oui
je raconte tout plus rapports d'origine
juive tunisienne
oui tout au contraire c'est formidable
votre famille votre travail la bouche
qu'est ce que vous aimeriez garder une
dimension de vous quelle quelle trace le
transformer les hasards en coup de boule
eu vraiment j'ai passé mon temps à
mentir l'orgie pas qu'il faille il faut
qu'elles manquent mais pour moi les
mensonges aient été salvateur ggg comme
eux rencontrés truffaut j'avais 12 ans
et je lui dis que je voulais être
metteur en scène douze ans et il me dit
mais quel genre enfin je me sens très
proche de l'univers de bermal usine ton
sentencieux
c'est une phrase que j'avais appris par
coeur dans le métro je sais pas qui
était batman mais ça va je trouvais que
ça faisait chic et grâce à cette phrase
il m'a fait venir sur le plateau
longuement des 400 coups si on est amis
on ne voit pas mieux dit une phrase mais
j'étais bouleversée de son attention de
son côté grand frère extra après
j'écrivais des scénarios bois même un
conte principe pour moi il me les
corriger voyez et c'est ça transformer
les rencontrant coup de bol et j'ai
commencé à travailler quand j'avais 15
ans et demi voyez et j'ai pas arrêté
depuis
et je voudrais lieu lure à côté de ça
quoi voyez cette espèce de passion que
j'ai eue de faire le bonheur oui le
bonheur et grâce à anita petit fils à
qui regardent la mer chez moi pays natal
en tunisie grâce à elle je coupe avec
l'orphelinat
ça a l'air bizarre je me sens créateur
de deux dynasties joue pas qu'on prenait
pour un fou n'est pas du tout le jeu
mais je me sens créateur de dynasty je
sens que la vie continue
oui eh ben c'est vachement bien de
pouvoir dire ça la vie continue c'est
bouleversant j'invite nos
téléspectateurs à lire cette lettre à
anita chez fayard souvenir de l'ardoisé
magique c'est drôle aussi s'interroge
beaucoup sur le monde tel qu'il vient le
monde ancien vous êtes assez acquiert le
grand père que vous êtes est inquiet
pour la petite fille qui va grandir mais
c'est plein d'espoir vous restez avec
nous serge moati on va terminer
un sujet grave un sujet discuté en ce
moment même dans l'hémicycle suis sûr
que ça va vous intéresser les violences
conjugales 126 féminicide selon le
dernier décompte de la fp en 2010 9,4
depuis le début de l'année on va faire
un gros plan sur une mesure discuter ce
soir la levée du secret médical pour
éviter les drames stéphanie des pierres
le problème c'est l'article 8 de la
proposition de loi la majorité proposent
de passer outre le secret médical en cas
de violence conjugale
le médecin pourra informer le procureur
de la république
s'il estime que sa patiente est en
danger faut-il briser le secret médical
pour protéger les femmes battues avec ou
sans l'aval des premières concernées
la question a suscité de gros débat avec
l'opposition et au sein même de la
majorité
ce serait une violence de plus pour ces
femmes que d'être trahis par leur
médecin
le risque ici c'est de priver les
victimes d'un rare et précieux soutien
qui pourrait engendrer une perte de
confiance importante pour libérer sa
parole qui est pourtant une étape
essentielle pour avoir la force de
porter plainte
nous sommes dans des cas extrêmes où les
femmes sont souvent prises et qu'elles
n'ont pas forcément la capacité de
prendre une décision qui est bonne pour
elle même et parfois aussi pour leurs
enfants
lorsque nous pouvons justement sauver
ces femmes faisons le le texte n'oblige
pas les médecins à rompre le secret
médical mais leur en donne la
possibilité
et seulement si la vie de la victime est
en danger et si la femme est sous
l'emprise de son conjoint galloway que
je rappelle que vous êtes député à la
république aux remarques d'ille et
vilaine se discute donc ce soir cette
mesure elle est sensible un parce
qu'elles touchent au lien de confiance
entre le médecin et ses patients ses
patientes souvent ou parfois qui peuvent
être victimes pour bien cerner déjà
cette mesure dans quels cas précisément
le médecin pour at il signalé
des soupçons de violences ou de mise en
danger de sa passion il le faut que le
médecin
l'idée du texte et ce qui est écrit
c'est que le médecin
déjà la personne soit majeur qu' il y
ait un phénomène d'emprise qu'ils soient
montrés et que du coup il ya un danger
immédiat qui soit prouvée c'est l'e3
j'irai paramètres à prendre en compte
par le médecin pour définir les médecins
doit ou le médecin peut le médecin peut
signaler
l'idée c'est toujours 8 négation de
faire c'est pour ça que quand on dit on
enlève le secret michael s'est pas tout
à fait juste dire qu'on ajoute une
possibilité de signalements vis-à-vis du
procureur donc c'est trouver le bon
équilibre
une ligne de crête qui est pas facile
quand vous êtes dans des situations et à
dire que c'est le médecin qui décide
s'il sent que sa patiente pourrait
arrêter de se faire soigner par exemple
ça que tu peux attendre c'est à lui de
faire cette remontée ce signalement au
procureur pour déclencher une autre
chaîne j'irai d'accompagnement pour ces
femmes qui sont dans une situation hyper
difficile et c'est important de signaler
justement cet équilibre là du médecin
qui passe le message est donc il doit
avoir cet intime conviction avant
d'aller voir le commissariat où le
procureur aurélien pradié il ya une
autre question qui se pose avec cette
mesure c'est l'accord il est nécessaire
d'avoir l'accord de la personne en
danger ou pas c'est le sujet extrêmement
extrêmement compliqué il faut que nous
ne payons pas de vue un seul objectif
qui est de protéger les victimes et nous
avons eu des débats extrêmement
intéressant dans l'hémicycle comme
souvent on a tendance presque par
intuition a considéré qu' évidemment la
levée du secret médical c'est une bonne
chose
femme se présente dans un cabinet
médical victime de coups instinctivement
les uns les autres et que moi nos
concitoyens avons presque le réflexe de
dire évidemment il faut lever ce que
lever le secret médical sauf que ça pose
sont en difficulté la première c'est que
le lien de confiance entre ces femmes
qui sont victimes de violence et le
médecin est un lien très singulier que
la plupart du temps dans ces femmes vont
voir le médecin s'en est allé pour
manifester qu'elles sont victimes de
violences elles y vont une fois deux
fois trois fois quatre fois parfois dix
fois et ce lien de confiance là il ne
peut pas être rompu si demain les femmes
victimes de violence considère que en
allant chez le médecin elle risque
d'être dénoncé
d'une certaine manière systématiquement
alors le grand danger c'est quand les
pertes dans la nature canaille plus chez
les médecins tout comme non pas d'une
audition vous nom des républicains
vous êtes sceptique mon nom personnel
j'essaie de me mettre d'accord avec
moi-même correctement groupes politiques
moi j'avais pas d'idée préconçue au
départ je pense qu'une part de doute
fait du bien en politique tendance qu'on
a parfois perdu depuis quelques temps et
souvent certaines des choses moi je ne
suis pas certain et en l'espèce j'ai
fini l'examen du texte en étant plutôt
défavorable la levée du secret médical
pour une raison très précise c'est que
je pense qu'on va mettre en danger
certaines femmes
je vous explique le parcours d'une femme
elle se présente chez son médecin elle
est victime de coups elle vient parce
qu'elle a une douleur au dos le médecin
détecte cas les victimes de coups c'est
assez facile à voir
au final le médecin va donc lui indiqué
que eelv a signalé au procureur elle
peut le refuser
le médecin peut contre son avis le
signaler au procureur avec cette
nouvelle loi
il va le signaler le procureur va lui
engagé une enquête puisqu'il aura besoin
de preuves
il va notamment demander à cette femme
d'aller passer un examen à l'unité
médico-légale judiciaire il va ensuite
la convoquer dans son cabinet mais si
cette femme dès le début n'a pas adhéré
à la démarche du dépôt de plainte
elle ne se présentera pas lui mjl ne se
présentera pas à la convocation par
contre l'auteur présumé des violences se
présentera la convocation et durant tout
ce temps là cette femme va être laissés
dans la nature sans aucune progrès qu'on
l'a mis en danger en cours à l'instant
cette proposition doit qui contient
cette mesure sur le secret médical vient
d'être adoptée à l'unanimité
mais tout de même vous vous entendez les
réserves sont importantes parce qu'elle
est ce qu'elle risque d'être
contre-productive cette mesure trop
choses que j'ai envie de dire un déjà
pour affiner le discours russie a dans
le texte je me permets c'est dire que le
médecin doit montrer ou avoir en tête
qui est un phénomène d'emprise c'est pas
juste
il ya une douleur au dos et ainsi de
suite et un phénomène plus globale et le
médecin doit être capable justement de
par la répétition parce qu'il a vu la
personne plusieurs fois il doit être
capable de regarder le contexte global
et les deux choses que je voulais
rajouter c'était un ça vient aussi de
l'ensemble du grenelle de
l'environnement on est allé voir on a
fait sauter des violences conjugales
grenelle des violences conjugales tu le
grenelle le grenelle les violences
conjugales tout à fait où il ya des
centaines de femmes victimes qui nous
fait voir leur parcours sur lequel on
est à la gendarmerie on est allés chez
le médecin on l
l'hôpital d'accord donc c'est un
équilibre entre le vécu de ces femmes là
et aussi de l'autre côté on a dit qu'on
ferait jamais sans les médecins ni
contre les médecins
et il ya eu une position de l'ordre des
médecins dans la journée justement sur
cette question là il faut expliquer que
l'ordre des médecins a donné son accord
il a même participé à la rédaction de
l'article en question donc l'idée c'est
de trouver
c'est donc ça peut passer en trois les
mettent exactement ni sans les médecins
c'est à dire que se trouver un équilibre
qui peuvent facile parce qu' un contexte
global il faut avoir en tête aussi de
tout ce qui est fait sur le parcours et
l'accompagnement futur de la victime ce
pacte ou de faire un signalement au
procureur si derrière évidemment voilà à
présent bien traduire à des grandes
difficultés si le débat que nous avons
eu cet après-midi moi j'ai eu le
sentiment je lis de manière très sereine
pour beaucoup travaillé sur ce sujet
j'ai le sentiment au fond que ce texte
là à les plus protégés les médecins que
les femmes
je comprends que l'ordre des médecins et
parce que il ya une ambiance il ya une
ambiguïté aujourd'hui dans le texte sur
le code pénal sur le fait que les
médecins pourraient dénoncer un acte de
violence conjugale et aurait rompu le
secret médical et pourrait en être
accusé donc ce texte là je le trouve
très inopérationnel en fait et dans les
débats d'ailleurs à plusieurs reprises
en abyme et il faut protéger les
médecins pour que s'ils dénoncent au
film dénonce pas ils ne soient pas
sujets à une poursuite judiciaire
quant aux femmes elles mêmes moi c'est
mon obsession c'est notre obsession de
vous même vous avez porté une
proposition doit adopter à l'unanimité
notamment sur le bracelet électronique
qui a un grenelle avec des mesures qui
viennent ici à l'assemblée être voté par
petits bouts parfois parce qu'il ya des
propositions de loi des uns et des
autres à l'isie de mots notre obsession
c'est de protéger les femmes et dans le
cas et c'est tout mon problème dans le
cas où elles n'adhèrent pas elle même à
la démarche du dépôt de plainte parce
qu'elles sont sous une emprise
considérable alors elle n'adhérons pas à
toutes les mesures de protection qui
pourrait venir ensuite au fond ce qui
est très difficile c'est que certains
médecins nous le disent
en seine saint denis où j'ai passé
beaucoup de temps je m'entraîne une
femme médecin qui me disait il me faut
au moins trois mois pour accompagner une
femme vers ce qui est l'acte le plus
fondateur qu'elle dépose elle même la
plaine parce qu'à ce moment là elle a
rompu l'emprise j'ai le sentiment qu'on
va à forcer la main de ses femmes on
risque de les perdre en chemin et c'est
ce qui m'inquiète je suis quoi tu dis
forcer la main par an
parce que parce qu'au final elles vont
aller chez leur médecin ou à new york
parce qu'elle vous soupçonner que le
médecin ne peut les dénoncer facilement
aujourd'hui un lien de confiance qui
fait que les y vont souvent en se disant
je vais pouvoir comme dans une
confession parler librement et le
médecin ne dénoncera jamais des actes
sans que moi j'en sois d'accord et donc
quand je dis forcer la main c'est que le
médecin demain avec cette loi pourra
rompre le secret signalé au procureur
même contre l'avis de la femme victime
de violence c'est là qu'il ya un lien de
confiance qui risquent de seront
importants c'est à dire que ce
simplement là il doit se faire avec le
médecin qui s'efforcent y assure
d'expliquer à sa patience
ce que je veux dire et là où je ne peux
le faire quand celle ci contre sont tous
d'avis mais en ces temps et forcé et
c'est dans le texte et contre son avis
d'aller d'aller jusqu'au bout et
deuxième chose ne suis pas du tout
d'accord c'est pas juste quand on a
porté plainte que l'emprise elle est
finie d'avenir que l'emprise elle peut
aller beaucoup plus loin
elle peut être plus encore présentes
mais vous avez dit voilà l'emprise que
j'ai portée non non quand on est en
reprise actuelle est beaucoup plus
friands précis quand on a déposé plainte
on commence à être dans un cheminement
de rupture avec l'emprise quand on
appelait affectueusement cantona pas
déposé plainte at et qu'on est juste
agir à d'autres textes en cadence est en
avance il ya encore beaucoup de choses
dans ce grenelle qui se traduiront
probablement par des textes de loi un
tout petit mot rapidement là dessus il
ya un mot qu'elle est forgée sur les
violences conjugales qui s'appelle les
féminicides on est en plein dans un
mouvement de prise de conscience et le
législateur et tâtonne on le voit il
avancé puis il se pose des questions
c'est difficile comment vous réagissez à
saint gély film c'est important et beau
vraiment fins et je suis bouleversée moi
quand je vous entends parler bouleverser
ce que je pense à toutes les femmes que
je connais ma petite fille dont je
parlais enfin bon ma fille bon enfin
bref ya eu une seule question qui me
taraude c'est que deviennent les mecs
dénoncé pas dénoncer extra mais qu'est
ce qui s'est passé nice épouvantable de
taper les femmes enfin c'est
épouvantable c'est un cauchemar c'est
dégueulasse comme qu'est ce qu'ils
deviennent alors là on va répondre vite
vraiment sur l'accompagnement et sur la
lutte contre les stéréotypes et avant et
après un engagement pour accompagner
aussi ses hommes qu'ils ont acteurs et
que se lancer et ils seront accompagnés
beaucoup plus facilement dans des
centres qui seront créés dont un est à
arras et pilotes deux centres gars des
centres et l'idée c'est de développer on
voit que c'est bien utile et que le
risque de récidive santé énormément et
de vendre dix minutes quand les juges et
des jugements des poursuites pourtant
des magistrats accepterait les c'est
l'heure de retrouver la chronique de
valeriy borchin elle s'est plongée
valérie brochard pour terminer cette
émission au coeur de la guérilla
parlementaire qui se prépare contre la
réforme des retraites allait ou ce soir
valérie la commission spéciale sur les
retraites continue ses auditions et
j'arrive tout de suite meriem en plateau
pour vous raconter le plan d' attaques
de la gauche parlementaire
[Musique]
valérie sans transition aucune vieux
absolue vous avez un plan d'attaqué
contre la réforme des retraites c'est à
dire c'est une partie d'échecs myriam
sur un plateau en cerisier les pour et
les contres avancent leurs pions alors
que les travaux de la commission
spéciale continué hier soir déjà les
prémices d'une attaque des anti réforme
se dessinait un front commun réunissant
les groupes de la gauche parlementaire
est il envisageable
clément méric l'un de nos journalistes a
tenté d'en savoir plus hier soir vers
23h à la fin de la première journée
d'auditions il a d'abord rencontré la
patronne des socialistes
d'abord chacun a ses expressions et nous
les garderons donc ça c'est une première
chose il ya toujours des moments on se
rejoint bien entendu il y aura donc des
initiatives communes peut-être travaux
restent mystérieuses
une tactique peut-être pour ne pas trop
dévoiler sa stratégie mais derrière elle
les députés insoumis et communistes ont
choisi eux d'annoncer clairement la
couleur pas l'intention de les laisser
tranquillement atteindre leur calendrier
leur objectif dans les temps impartis
donc on a aussi quelques leviers pour ça
et on se réserve le droit de les
utiliser
on va faire rentrer la colère de la rue
dans l'hémicycle on va utiliser tout
l'arsenal législatif en notre possession
motion par voie référendaire
motion de censure amendement pour avoir
des débats de fond
bref tout l'arsenal va être mis en
branle pour que la vie de ce
gouvernement sur ce mauvais projet de
casse du socle des retraites par
répartition ne soit pas un long fleuve
tranquille
donc la mairieà mans on commence à
comprendre que c'est bien tous ensemble
qu'ils vont déplacer leur tour et leurs
cavaliers parlementaire et ce matin la
nouvelle officielle tombe
regardez jean luc mélenchon annonce à
nos confrères de bfm tv le dépôt d'une
motion de censure pour faire de
l'obstruction à l'assemblée en clair un
accord de principe a été trouvé entre
les socialistes et apparentés la gauche
démocrate et républicaine et la france
insoumise
il compte déposer une motion de censure
contre le gouvernement il faut un
minimum de 58 députés pour les faire
pour le faire et bien ensemble ces trois
groupes parlementaires peuvent atteindre
ce minimum mais attention myriam
subtilité dans la manoeuvre
cette motion sera déposée après le 17
février dans l'hémicycle c'est à dire
après l'entrée du tijd danger mais
retardé révéla un ralentir la machine de
la majorité un examen en procédure
accélérée que dénonce tous les opposants
à la réforme quinze jours de débats une
seule lecture par les deux chambres un
rouleau compresseur qui agace même à
droite
regardez aujourd'hui le parlement ne
dispose ni du temps ni de toutes les
données nécessaires pour évaluer amende
et discuter de cette réforme
tout est mis en oeuvre pour priver le
parlement et donc les français d'un vrai
débat sur la réforme des retraites
motion censure monsieur référendaire sur
le fond aussi évidemment avec de très
nombreux amendements bref à partir du 17
février prochain ça va chauffer dans la
missive à l'autriche les par lise
croteau abattant des essais et oui c'est
ça c'est tout problème les oppositions
unis vont tout faire beau retard
exactement ça pour rien
les oppositions feront tous servent
matti latvala n'a jean et pull 3 mars
prochain c'est à dire juste avant la
trêve municipal soit décalé donc tout
pour que le texte n'arrive for dinah fin
avril
donc tout pour que la réforme ne soit
pas définitivement adopté avant l'été la
partie ne fait que commencer
rassurez vous on encore du temps pour
expliquer tout ça ici mais oui sur le
plateau des steppers merci
merci beaucoup vous faire doit être cité
la fin de cette émission lettre à anita
ces chiffres fayard j'ai recommandé par
l'équipe de la rédaction
merci à vous de votre fidélité très
belle soirée soirée documentaire tout de
suite ma demain
[Musique]